when did you break the news to the
families of these kids that you had
obtained footage of the two judges we
one of the things I dreaded in this film
was to sharing the film with the
families and all the projects that we've
done on fiction work that we've done you
know we say look you know we're going to
show you the film before the public sees
it privately in this particular case we
knew I week I knew we would do that when
it was all done and I knew that would be
the first time they'd find out that the
villain the person they hated the most
perhaps in the whole world was in this
movie too and I dreaded it because I had
developed a rapport not just with the
judges and families but with both sides
I mean there was I had a rapport with
both the villain of the victim because
the only way you can get an interview
you know they had to trust you sure so
we so we went into a regular movie
theater one family at a time and the
first half hour of the time that we
blocked was me telling them first I have
to tell you that judge ciavarella and
judge Conahan her in this movie and let
that sink in and of course they were all
shocked some felt betrayed initially and
then we showed the movie and then we
spent the next hour after the movie
talking about their feelings about what
they just saw and the the the first
screening for all of them was a bit of a
blur but they were but but they saw it
again and over the course of time they
really come to completely appreciate why
it's important to have the villain in
the film they all support the film I
mean even the judges daughters judges
haven't been able to see the film but
the judge judge Ciavarella daughters
have seen it as well and it's been
remarkable I think it's one of the most
remarkable things about the project for
me is how the families have reacted to
seeing themselves and having their
stories which are so personal you know
splayed open for the for the public to
see and how much integrity they have
displayed it's pretty remarkable
you